[Musique]
il se voit que la beauce et dans son
sourire non
faire jaillir au cours de mon
mais soudain somme
ma mère
là
[Musique]
je
moi ma priorité c'est l'éducation c'est
les écoliers le maire on ne demande pas
des discours on lui demande tu
comprennes seul on peut en fait rien ça
ne s'est pas posé le pays qui m'a dit
m'a donné le chemin de la vie c'est la
france c'est la france
[Musique]
j'ai milité dans la société civile j'ai
milité pour le droit de la femme et puis
un certain moment je me suis dit c'est
bien l'humidité est ce qu'il faudrait
pas une chose prendre carrément les
rênes des décisions parce que je peux
peut-être faire plus au lieu de dire
faites ceci fait tuera peut-être aussi
moins je peux faire ce peu de choses
peut-être mais je peux être contribuer
un peu
donc j'ai changé de côté les jardins du
côté de la déclamation pour aller vers
la réalisation option voilà l'action je
me suis dit je vais être candidat pour
voir ce que je peux apporter à la
population au lieu seulement de dire il
faut faire ce sucre ça va moi je vais
voir qu'est ce qu'on peut faire ensemble
qu'est ce que je peux apporter ces
populations et je me suis portée
candidate
et c'est comme ça que je suis devenu
maire pour moi les assises m'ont aidé
a amiens a mis en oeuvre
décernés de de savoir aussi qu'à trois
petites faut frapper
c'est important parce que seul on ne
peut rien faire
ça ne c'est pas possible et puis quelle
priorité parce que quand on a tendance à
vouloir tout faire et c'est pas possible
de plus faire la part de chance parce
que quand vous dites c'est complexe mais
ça devient moins compliqué grâce à ces
assises la moitié principal c'est l'eau
potable
il faut que chaque comorien puisse avoir
plutôt qu'il soit riche ou pas mais
c'est un non d'exiger
qu'est ce que l'état peut nous apporter
qu'est ce que nous pouvons faire pour
aider à ce que nos administrés notre
apathie maladie parce qu'il ya trop de
déchet parce qu'il ya trop de
de mouche hier dernièrement la section
de chez moi pour me dire il ya trop de
gras dans mon cas en tout cas théâtre
des déchets oui c'est vrai et moi je
dois trouver des points j'ai parlé je
peux pas leur dire c'est pas dans mes
compétences non il faut savoir que rien
ne peut tomber du ciel il faut se battre
pour que ça arrive
et puis il faut avoir un objectif mais
si avec ça dans un pays comme les
comores quand on est femme et fois que
je vais avoir dans la parole il faut
faire deux fois plus qu'un homme c'est
vrai je pense l inverse vannes en
annonçant également par une société
matriarcale où pour moi j'avais pulsions
qui est comorienne ce sont les meilleurs
moments du monde
allawi pour la femme au foyer mais
imaginez qu ici la femme n'a pas de
l'espace public s'exprimer parce que
toutes les places publiques
appartiennent aux hommes
donc pour s'exprimer il faut se faire de
la place
il faut il faut se faire tout petit
d'abord se faire accepter parce que les
hommes sérail j'ai un peu peur des faits
des femmes il faut faire se faire tout
petit
ce fonds sert et après quand tous ces
faits la place et là on commence à
parler et c'est comme ça que ça se passe
je vous assure vous demander à toutes
les femmes on commence pas par attac
lire sinon au bout balard au top il faut
se faire il faut se faire glisser entre
c'est le cheval de troie voilà c'est
jamais facile pour une femme de devenir
mère je connais ma collègue rennais sont
enthousiastes mais c'est jamais facile
souvent dans une société également vous
mettre tout le poids lourd
et des traditions et d'habitants ça vaut
aussi pour la métropole la réunion
je suis aussi passé par là et donc il y
aller pratiquer d'acceptation des ae des
zones sans opposition les femmes de ce
faux espoirs aux hommes les hommes ce
vote favorable c'est bien le travail des
équipes partaient il faut construire
parce que si on ne construit pas jamais
gouvernance ne pourra fonctionner de
manière vraiment démocratique et de
manière d'agir dès que j'ai ans je suis
qu'elle était là je me suis dit il faut
que je la raconte pas il faut quelques
jeux qu'elle voit qui je sais que je ne
la connaissent pas ce que je sais
qu'elle a fait beaucoup de choses pour
la femme dans l'océan indien
et encore moi et donc je suis allé à ses
enfants j'ai même demandé à ce que dans
notre association ici de la plateforme
comores pour l'océan indien puisse la
rencontrer pour discuter parce que j'ai
vu déjà dans les entrées elle a beaucoup
d'expérience les modèles les devenir
modèle alors je suis michel lambert je
suis le directeur des services
techniques de la ville de la courneuve
je représente le maire gilles poulx au
sein de cette délégation de la courneuve
donc qui est présente aux comores
aujourd'hui pour faire le point sur les
projets de coopération que nous avons en
charge pour les nouveaux projets à
mettre en place
nous avons une forte communauté
comorienne sur la ville est investie sur
les projets comoriens depuis plusieurs
dizaines d'années depuis comme je le dis
tout à l'heure 1999 on a signé la
première convention en 2003 mais nous
sommes une sommes intervenus sur la base
de l'association associative de
différents projets depuis ces années là
et on est partie prenante avec les
comoriens puisque la ville compte 103
nationalité on a une ville
multiculturelle ce qu'on appelle une
ville monde voilà est donc au travers de
ce que nous réalisons comores on
participe à l'élaboration au mieux-être
de
les populations locales ont dit de
dunkerque elle est la troisième ville
comorienne de france
je ne sais pas si cela reflète la
réalité physique et numérique de la
communauté comorienne mais elle a
toujours été extrêmement présente à
dunkerque c'est une diaspora qui est
très impliqué dans la vie quotidienne
dans la vie locale et c'est à son
instigation principalement que la
coopération a débuté à la fin des années
90 et au début des années 2000 la
coopération décentralisée est en train
de prendre une vitesse supérieure on a
on était aux balbutiements des
nécessaires et aux populations mais là
on n'est plus aux populations et au
développement d'une partie de la planète
qui aujourd'hui lydia au ciani il est
rare de traverser un territoire avec
autant de deux d'énergie azir nous veut
arriver ou sans cette volonté de réussir
et d'évoluer pour un monde meilleur
oui on le sent et cette énergie là est
pour moi la plus grande des richesses
que les commandes savon
[Musique]
la mort
mon sport
quand le gars moi
[Musique]
actional on est juste là pour les
finitions donc pour toutes a été acheté
tous les matériaux sont sortis à payer
avec les dix mille autres qui ont été
versés on a avancé
cette somme est bien consciente de la
subvention qu'on à l'avancé au col
achètent ou est-ce que moi mon but c'est
de finir sur l'état tech avoir les clés
avant de l'asean a vendu 10
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci sa peau
l'archipel des comores a joué son rôle
dans le peuplement de l'île de la
réunion
qu'il s'agisse de la période
esclavagiste même de l'engagisme même au
début du 20e siècle on a des comorienne
qui arrive en tant qu'engagé qui vont
travailler au port qui vont travailler
dans les plantations et la population
réunionnaise pour certaines parties a
une ascendance comorienne issus des
bantous issus de ces sultans arabe
austronésiens et donc il est important
aujourd'hui que la jeunesse réunionnaise
prennent conscience que les comoriennes
ne sont pas arrivées d'hyères bien
évidemment une migration plus récentes
années 90 2000
mais dans l'histoire du document de
lille les comores font partie de
l'histoire de la population réunionnaise
c'est ça c'est important
il ya tout un travail à faire sur les
généalogies nous avons commencé à
l'université à travailler là dessus
par exemple par rapport à la famille
humblot une grande famille métropolitain
installé aux comores qui ont participé
au développement économique la société
bambao contre il des postes de pouvoir
dans la politique mais aussi qui se sont
métissés à des comoriens il ya de mixité
chrétiens musulmans ces populations et
cette famille jour on les retrouve
aujourd'hui à la réunion ils sont un
certain nombre et dans le reste de ses à
l'indien donc c'est important de voir
que les comores finalement dans la
première partie du 20ème siècle était un
pôle attractif de nombreux réunionnais
aller chercher du travail aux comores la
société bamba au kirov différentes
essences société bamba au nez aux
comores qui va se développer aussi à
madagascar donc l'image des comores la
première partie du 20ème siècle elle est
inversée c'est un pôle attractif
les réunionnais sont partis aux
seychelles mais aussi son parti aux
comores alors que la réunion de cette
colonisation interminable de
l'entre-deux-guerres connaît la misère
donc il est important que les jeunes
aujourd'hui connaissent aussi pour voir
que l'océan indien d'indiennes océanie
connaissez logique et parfois ils
peuvent s'inverser donc beaucoup
d'humilité et beaucoup de mains tendues
finalement constructive pour nos cousins
comoriens
[Musique]
le reprendre mais là je vais reprendre
la réalité institutionnelle nous la
connaissons la réalité humaine nous la
voyons en images
mais la palper sur le terrain la sentir
dans le coeur et le battement des hommes
et des femmes qu'on rencontre ça vous
donne une autre lecture de l'afrique tic
que nous devons faire aller
s'il y avait une volonté politique de
régler le problème de ce pays parce que
c'est pas l'argent qui manque
nous avons beaucoup dead nous avons des
aides qui accomplit nous la diaspora ont
fait on fait beaucoup de choses on se
met à la place du gouvernement
aujourd'hui est ce que c'est normal
qu'une association construit une école
l'école c'est à l'état une association
doit aider des familles en difficulté
une association doit accompagner des
élèves une association doit faire des
sorties culturelles de sortie sportive
mais écoles ou des routes ça ça
appartient à l'état de le faire et nous
on le fait et heureusement que la
diaspora que nous on pense à nos parents
à nos cousins nos cousines parce qu'on
envoie de l'argent tous les mois on fait
vivre ce pays mais on n'est pas aidé
nous on a pris une décision politique en
assemblée plénière pour voter un budget
pour accompagner le fonctionnement payer
tout ça pendant trois années
c'est quand même si ça représente un
effort particulier un pour une
collectivité comme comme la nous parce
qu'il s'agit d'un problème de santé
publique
on ne peut pas accepter de voir des ddd
comme auriez après
des kwassa kwassa mourir en mer pour
venir se faire soigner quand ils
arrivent dans un état lamentable
allez trouver une place au chm à mayotte
parfois ils sont renvoyés sur la réunion
une prise en charge jusqu'à trois mois
pour des gens qui parfois se trouve dans
un état de santé proche de 2,2 de
l'amont c'est parce que c'est fatal
vraiment c'est vraiment fatale
[Musique]
alors amoureux les lie
elle a dit elle est contente elle
remercie dieu les bénisse tous les vins
elle va bien oui en ce moment on en a
beaucoup on en a moins une quinzaine qui
viennent des comores ça fait ça fait
plus d'un mois on va dire à peu près
deux mois qu'on a beaucoup de patients
qui viennent que des promeneurs et du
coup on les traite en urgence puisqu'ils
sont au chm je pose la chaîne sont
overbookés du coup c'est nous qu'on s'en
occupe s'est plaint le soir s'est plaint
la journée c'est plat c'est tout le
temps plein à un moment donné on ne
pourra plus tous les prendre ça c'est
sûr et certain
parce que le souci c'est qu'il y en a
même ceux qui sont ici les morts ex ante
s'ils veulent récupérer leur place ici
du coup on ne peut pas puisqu'on reçoit
les gens du chm les comoriens qui arrive
du coup ça pose souci aussi donc un
moment donné on sera ce sera comblé ce
sera bouche on ne pourra pas les prendre
et analyse arrivent ils sont peu à moi
ils sont pas dans un très bon état pas
puisqu'ils ont fait la traversée le
temps qu'ils arrivent yanez n'ont pas de
famille ils ont pas de moyens de
locomotion du coup c'est nous qu'on s'en
occupe avec la cadre avec les accords de
la rs du coup c'est nous qu'on se
dévouent pour leur trouver un chauffeur
un taxi puisque c'est vital ce flux
incessant et
et kim et mettant la vie des patients en
danger on va dire la patiente elle
deviendra incontournable je pense que
aux comores ils ont aussi le droit
d'avoir des soins et de la dialyse et
pour pouvoir répondre à cette demande
il sera évident d'ouvrir cet entonnoir
et de positionner les comores dans la
triangulaire réunion mayotte comores
pour les dialysés
j'aimerais également à cette occasion
vous parler des deux conventions de
partenariat qui devront être signée
entre le conseil départemental et les
autorités comoriennes
l'une portant donc sur le sm a et
l'autre sur la question de santé et
d'accompagnement des dialysés dialysés
qui viennent des comores qui arrive à
mayotte qui sont pris en charge par une
part la rs mais sur une durée limitée et
qui pour beaucoup se retrouvent aussi
parfois orienté vers la réunion et qui
sont pris en charge par le chu ou bien
l'hôpital de sainte clotilde
donc c'est un gros dossier de santé mais
qui concerne pas seulement la prise en
charge de malades et qui devient une
question humanitaire puisque beaucoup de
ces malades se rendent souvent pas ce à
quoi ça aa à à mayotte pour se faire
soigner et obtenir des soins en mille
ans moi ce que j'ai compris ladjali sa
vie à moins d'avoir une greffe de rein
donc voilà c'est vital passer des
maladies chroniques
il a dit qu'il souffrait beaucoup parce
que déjà depuis qu'il est venu ici la
wii d'or il galère
et en plus il a même pas d'argent pour
pouvoir renouveler son séjour et il n'a
même pas de sou quad pour s'acheter à
manger quoi pour la rs normalement ou
ici pendant trois mois c'est remboursé
donc apprécié les trois mois c'est pas
remboursés c'est pour ça qu'on doit
absolument qu'ils puissent faire leurs
papiers régularisées leurs papiers pour
pouvoir avoir une sécurité celle qui
puisse les prendre en charge
mais s'il n'y a pas de sécurité sociale
est en sursis comme vous dites voilà
puisque c'est vital sans dialyse une
heure nous avions eu préoccupation forte
du président azali sur deux dossiers
particuliers d'une part la mise en place
de deux centres de dialyse à à moroni à
anjouan mais également de pouvoir
effectivement mettre en place de sm à 1
à moroni t1 en jour alors s'il est vrai
que la santé publique est un est un
dossier prioritaire avant de rebondir à
on a également l'éducation et en
particulier la formation professionnelle
qui est extrêmement importante
l'armée comorienne va pouvoir encadrer
des jeunes en difficulté qui pourront
sur des métiers de base
immédiatement à la fin de l'heure de
leur formation
travailler sur les projets que nous
comptons mettre en oeuvre avec un je
vois au niveau de la santé dans notre
pays
les hôpitaux quel est l'état des
hôpitaux les médecins qui n'ont pas le
matériel qu'il faut pour soigner les
patients
j'espère que le gouvernement va bouger
dans ce domaine là parce que c'est un
pays touristique mais je pense que si
les conditions de santé ne sont pas
réunies on aura personne dans ce pays
n'est au centre hospitalier dé de la
communauté s'est fait par le village de
zuani en étroite collaboration avec la
avec les huit villages qui le composent
et les panneaux photovoltaîques que vous
voyez sur le toit c'est un projet qui a
été réalisé par l'association et wad
c'est une association comme on l'avait
dit au départ qui a été fait par les
ressortissants iraniens résidant à la
réunion et qui a été
et encouragée et soutenue par la commune
de bras-panon
alors parce que je lui propose c'est de
faire un diagnostic des niveaux
appareils et des besoins on le ferait
avec une pensée on refera on refera
venir un expert c'est à dire puis
d'autres ce cahier des charges on fera
venir un expert chez nous pour justement
faire des propositions et compliqué ce
qui a été fait et peut-être aussi
changer les anciens pas nous mettre des
panneaux de nouvelle génération
pas de nouvelle génération plus
productif en électricité et en étant
plus nombreux puisque vous avez de
nouveaux équipements
ce qui est normal quand il n'y avait pas
on a voulu donner stabilité
d'électricité je pense que c'est plus
mauvais qu'on pût je vous en remercie de
nous avoir les japonais là dessus
la deuxième étape aujourd'hui c'est se
dire on va créer nos besoins du besoin
je vais donner petite phrase d'albert
estaing qui a dit le monde ne sera pas
détruit par ceux qui font le mal mais
par ceux qui le regardent sans rien
faire donc il faut bouger faut se battre
article 1er les hommes naissent et
demeurent libres et égaux en droits
les distinctions sociales ne peuvent
être fondées que sur l'utilité commune
[Musique]
ces droits sont la liberté la propriété
la sûreté et la résistance à
l'oppression
[Musique]
le principe de toute souveraineté réside
essentiellement dans la nation
[Musique]
la loi n'a le droit de défendre que les
activités nuisibles à la société
tout ce qui n'est pas défendu par la loi
ne peut être empêché la loi est
l'expression de la volonté générale
tous les citoyens étant égaux à ses yeux
sont également admissibles à toutes
dignités places et emplois publics
nul homme ne peut être accusé arrêté ni
détenu que dans les cas déterminés par
la loi
à
tout homme est présumé innocent jusqu'à
ce qu'il ait été déclaré coupable
nul ne doit être inquiété pour ses
opinions même religieuses
[Musique]
la libre communication des pensées et
des opinions est un des droits les plus
précieux de l'homme tout citoyen peut
donc parler écrire imprimer librement
sauf à répondre de l'abus de cette
liberté dans les cas déterminés par la
loi
la garantie des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen nécessite une force publique
cette force est donc constitué pour l'
avantage de tous
la propriété étant un droit inviolable
et sacré nul ne peut en être privé si ce
n'est lorsque la nécessité publique
légalement constatée l'exigé évidemment
[Musique]